(audience cheering and applauding)
- (indistinct) you name it.
Welcome back.
Everybody, the royal family,
the D'Amelios are here.
They are known around the world
as the first family of Tik Tok.
I think you're the first
family of social media.
But there are some fun
facts you might not know.
Did you know that Dixie
was a sick BMX biker,
ranking fifth in the nation?
(audience cheering and applauding)
Where does it end with you guys?
And fun fact about Charli,
she got 15 tattoos in one year.
I like it.
- Thank you.
They're like this big.
- I'm looking, I don't see any on you.
- There's some on my fingers.
- [Dixie] They're so tiny.
- There's one right here.
- [Drew] Oh, they are teeny tiny.
- Oh my back.
They're very small.
- All right, well please welcome everybody
Charli, Dixie, Heidi
and Mark D'Amelio.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Now, out of curiosity, Dixie and Charli,
how do you navigate having hundreds
of millions of followers,
having millions of
people know who you are?
- I feel like we don't think about it.
I mean we do what we do,
and we post online,
but we just try to live our lives,
hang out with our family.
We live together, we're roommates,
so we come home at the end of the day,
and are sisters,
and just...
- I think it's also still
having that connection
with the people that knew you before,
and my hometown friends are a big part
of my life.
My family's a big part of my life.
And I'm still their daughter
at the end of the day,
and they have rules,
and I have to respect my parents.
And she's still my big sister.
It feels the same.
- So boundaries,
what is your advice for having
extremely recognizable
kids on social media,
and what's your advice for parents
who are just going "God,
I didn't sign up for this
"in our generation"?
- I think for us, we,
the foundation is what we
set with the boundaries,
we're your parents, we're not,
you have friends, you don't need friends.
You have parents and rules and boundaries.
But from what they knew as kids,
that didn't change when all
this happened on social media,
that stayed the constant.
And I think them knowing
this is what it is,
and it still feels the same helped.
- What is your advice to parents out there
who are having kids,
or even themselves trying to build
a life for themselves on social media?
Because that is a really amazing
new opportunity for
everybody in a positive way.
- Yeah, I think the tone
has changed over time where now
everyone understands that you can
make a career on social media,
so I think it's up to
parents to get involved,
but not to be the center of attention.
Heidi and I have tried to balance it out
where we're involved with the process,
but we never try to overshadow the girls.
It's their show, we're
just along for the ride.
- Now switching gears a little bit,
I do have two daughters, sister advice.
When should I lean in,
when should I lean out?
- Us, we hated each other.
- So bad, did not talk.
- [Drew] What ages?
- All of middle school,
until we got into high school together,
then we became best friends.
She would come with me to
every party on the weekend.
It just happened out of nowhere though.
We would go weeks without talking.
- And we lived,
we shared a wall.
- Yeah.
But now I don't remember the last time
we actually argued.
- Yeah.
- Over anything.
- And now we live together just us two,
so that's pretty fun.
I notice the times where
it gets the most annoying
when we fight is when they chime in,
and they're like "What are
you guys arguing about?"
- "You guys are sisters."
- We were already over it.
We were over it 10 minutes ago.
- [Heidi] We cause more problems.
- [Charli And Dixie] Yes.
- When parents get involved
in siblings' fights,
I think that makes it so much worse.
We're done.
- We get over it.
- Oh my God, I'm so excited right now,
you don't even understand.
This is such, I feel the same way.
That's my gut instinct, I'm
like let them work it out.
Not about everything
or when it's dangerous,
obviously we all known the line.
But yes, oh my God.
(Drew yelling)
Thank you.
I'm so sorry, this is such great news.
- Anytime they get involved
it makes it so much worse,
and then we just get mad at them.
Oh my God, they're so annoying.
- We're like okay, get over it.
- To be fair, they'll argue,
she's texting me, she's
calling me about the other one.
So-
- [Drew] So what do you do?
How do I do this?
- I step in.
- No, don't get involved.
- Just listen.
- I try to tell the-
- I try to tell each other
where the other one was
trying to come from.
Meanwhile, they've already made up.
He and I are still like
what should we do, whatever,
and they are so moved on.
I'm like "I'm not doing this anymore.
"We're going over here,
you guys figure it out."
I don't get involved anymore.
- [Charli] It took a minute.
- This is so helpful.
You guys are doing dancing
with the stars together.
- Us two.
- So how do you do that?
How does that work?
- Well, we tried the
whole smack talk thing
for a few days,
and then I was like "I'm done with this
"because as my competitor
"I can't come to you
"and be like oh my God I'm so stressed."
So we can't do this.
And then I also have to keep in mind
that she is my mother,
and I can't be too mean
about the competition thing.
But I don't know,
I feel like we've never
competed against each other in anything,
so it's, we're learning.
- Yeah.
But I'm her biggest cheer,
both of their biggest cheerleader,
I don't think that's gonna ever change,
but at the same time I'm competitive,
so I wanna win too.
- [Charli] We keep going
back and forth with it.
- This is definitely a weird
feeling for me as a mom to,
it doesn't feel right.
So I'm figuring it out.
I don't know how you get through that.
- And I mean you are known as a dancer.
You are an incredible dancer.
I have watched all your videos.
I love your incredible,
you are such an amazing dancer.
But other than dancing,
if you were to have to pick a lane,
an occupation, what would it be?
- Do you remember what you used to say?
- No.
- You wanted to be a psychologist
'cause you had a lot of bad therapists.
- Oh yeah, that was one thing
because I've had my fair
share of very bad therapists.
- I thought you wanted to run a hotel.
- [Heidi] Oh, I forgot about that.
- Oh yeah, I was going to go
to school for hospitality.
I was going to go to college for that,
and be on the dance team.
- Well maybe you could
have a therapy hotel.
(indistinct) check into one of those.
- That seems like a really good vacation.
- I'm not kidding.
Actually, why is this not a thing?
(Charli laughing)
All right, we're not
done with the D'Amelios.
Up next, it's gonna be the final five.
We're getting to know this family.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)